hallo mein name ist luca und vor einigen
wochen habe ich bereits auf komische
asiatische werbung reagiert
[Musik]
das video kann mega gut bei euch an
deswegen habe ich mir gedacht er gehe
ich heute auf das video funny ist agent
commercial compilation top funny on
television
sind sie noch weiter ist habe er an ich
will wirklich überhaupt nicht irgendwie
deren kultur in irgendeiner form
beleidigen und es soll auch nicht so
rüber kommen jetzt ob ich das tun wollen
würde aber ich finde ich weiß nicht also
dass hier allein da ist ja das ist ja
nur voll mit verschiedenen farben bringt
ihnen schmuck und irgendwie mir kommt so
ein bisschen sofort ab weil es bei denen
der region oder in dem raum oder keine
ahnung was so ist als wenn jede werbung
so krasser sein müsste es geht nicht
darum wie kreativ ist man sondern
hauptsache ganz bunt und in ganz komisch
vor kanada die so ich weiß nicht was es
hier geht
das ist auf jeden fall beruhigt dass
manche glaube ich und das ist eine
werbung für ein auto
ich dachte erst als diese schilder
hochgehalten haben das ist vielleicht
ein übersetzungs app geht oder so weit
weg ist vom hirsch und bananen oder also
wenn sie nicht im ferrari geht dann weiß
ich auch nicht er hat sogar bananen in
dem in den ohren oder fliegt mit den
bananen weg irgendwie geht es in diesem
video nicht darum dass darauf reagieren
sondern vielmehr dass sich erraten muss
für was das ganze überhaupt bewerbung
ist plötzlich hat der cheerleader im
garten leserbindung leber selbst in
ihrer bewerbung und ich glaube es geht
um nudeln aber die das dann auch
denk denken die dann ist es bei denen
dann so dass man sich denken die haben
so ein cooles kostümen menschen dingen
von denen kaufe ich dann jetzt die
nudeln ja hier sind pferde und das ist
zum ersten mal wirklich eine werbung wo
ich mir denke wir können so auch in
europa laufen also das pferd ist zu
klein und kann da nicht drüber springen
und jetzt geschafft dass das pferd durch
das klares nach amazon werbung also ich
meine klar amazon ist es auch ein
westliches unternehmen trotzdem verstehe
ich das auch hier jetzt nicht so auf
einmal so einen reifen bestellen falls
euer pferd zu klein ist und wie man
hindernisse springen
[Musik]
okay das ist der typ von pipi oder das
war ja damals dieses video wurde gesagt
hat herr wie paypal apple pendant ist
das pipi und den haben jetzt anscheinend
für fanta auch gekauft also yahia seine
komische werbung irgendwie springen die
ausland orte und jetzt geschieht
square enix okay ich glaube das ist ein
fernseher oder es nächstes mal nix man
im spiel aber auch wie das bewerben
irgendwann überdimensionale figur
läuft da durch die stadt an den häusern
vorbei und berührt auch die häuser und
alles wird in eisversetzungen die person
dann auch noch ein auge muss und es ist
eine werbung für tatsächlich ein spiel
habe ich aber was richtig erraten keine
ahnung worum es hier wieder geht
vielleicht könntest du ganzes trailer
sein er schleudert gegen welche sachen
auf die person und er geht die ganze weg
also vermutlich denke es ist ein
filmtrailer
und obwohl er den tod geschossen das
wäre und jetzt ins auge
und es ist eine werbung für ein getränk
also wir hatten
beginnen ja dieses komische wo diese
beiden personen gegenüber stand und das
getrunken haben unser phlow gegen die
limetten und zitronen rum dann hatten
wir diesen fanta ppp typen jetzt haben
wir ihnen hier
der mit seinen deckelung von seinem
getränk andere leute abschießt und tötet
ich finde halt werbung ist entweder auf
der einen seite dafür da um den
zuschauer emotional zu berühren oder auf
der anderen seite und dem zuschauer zu
zeigen hey wenn du unser produkt kaufs
wärst du genauso toll die die personen
der werbung aber hier wird dir einfach
noch impliziert hague auf unser produkt
du kannst andere leute mit unserem
deckel töten
auch hier sehe ich noch nicht für
richtig worum es geht aber ich glaube um
irgendein spiel also ja es geht um spiel
aber ich bin das ding ist halt auch bei
uns im fernsehen laufen halt gar nicht
so richtig werbungen für irgendwelche
handyspiele sondern das einzige was in
letzter zeit häufig sehr tiefer werbung
für das neue fifa aber es ist ja bei uns
jetzt auch nicht so dass seine werbung
im fernsehen
ich meine ich gucke auch nicht so viel
fernsehen daher kann ich das vielleicht
nicht richtig beurteilen hier geht um
mario also vermutlich um einen super
mario golfspiel oder irgendwie so will
ich mal beraten
ja es geht um hier spielt auf einmal
channels jetzt machen sie irgendwie was
anderes aber es geht auf jeden fall
wieder auf gegend ein computerspiel bzw
nintendo spielen als krass dass er
wirklich so viel werbung für für games
läuft moment das ist das war gar keine
werbung fürs spiel
es geht auch hier wieder um irgendein
getränk ich dachte es geht um spiel weil
sie hat halt einen gameboy in der hand
also nintendo ds oder kanal um das
modell genau heißt und da laufen halt
mario luigi todd und prinzessin peach da
irgendwie rum und so weiter und so fort
aber die verben anscheinend die werben
schon mit den figuren aus dem spiel
zuerst man denkt hey meine figur aus
meinem lieblings spiel trinkt dieses
getränk
keine ahnung worum es hier geht
um den film
auf
sie macht er macht
durch den 2
es geht um kekse es geht um kekse was
gesagt vermutlich es geht um pokémon ich
finds ich weiß ja zum tausendsten ist
krass wie viel werbung dafür games im
fernsehen läuft sonst ist die nächste
werbung und das ist einfach eine katze
die um die welt rum läuft und alles
mögliche sieht jetzt ist sie gerade in
frankreich jetzt am schiefen turm von
pisa und es geht um sex allgemein nicht
ich meine wir sind schon der nächste
werbung auch hier wieder der zeit
irgendwas es geht um was geht es hier
überall so schwarze striche und um was
ich weiß ich wer einfach nur verwirrt
dort fernsehen schauen würde in der tat
hier sind einfach ganz viele damen am
strand und tanzen
ich denke mal es geht um eine urlaubs
plattform von wegen ihr könnt ihr euren
urlaub buchen aber es geht um kaugummis
pop und hey gar nix berg hier ist eine
person die gegen godzilla kämpft und die
frau ist aus gibt mehrere godzilla die
als alle dahin fliegen und beobachten
diese godzilla ist also ich will jetzt
beweisen nicht worum es geht
ich habe keine ahnung nächste werbung
drei mädels die auf die style durch die
stadt laufen und es geht glaube ich
wiederum getränk sonst wärs da hinten
nicht gewesen angezeigt geworden gewesen
gerät ich kann nicht mehr reden
ad astra wird mich so krass diese
werbungen ich weiß ich bin so so reitz
überflutet irgendwie weil es ist alles
farbig man sieht überall irgendwie ist
es krasser dollar da läuft ein riesiges
monster wieder durch die stadt
ich weiß nicht bin ich der einzige der
denkt dass das too much ist für eine
werbung ich meine das habe ich letztens
ausstellung gesagt wenn ich einfach
irgendwie marketing mensch wäre von
ihnen im großen unternehmen weil wenn
deine werbung im fernsehen läuft bist du
ja ein großes unternehmen und von den
größten unternehmen kennt man ja auch
die logos
beispielsweise werden ja fanta und wenn
ich jetzt der marketing mensch von fanta
wäre und ich wüsste hey wir haben budget
für eine zehn sekunden werbung im
fernsehen würde ich einfach ein fand
allein blenden
ich würde einfach fett ein fanta logo
einblenden so viele leute die das sich
anschauen würden würden sich dann
wahrscheinlich denken hängt mein
fernseher ist einfach nur ein phantom
geht weiter das wäre eine sache da hast
du keine kosten hinsichtlich ey wir
müssen dann fällt es monster durch eine
stadt laufen lassen sondern einfach nur
das fanta logo und jeder wird sich
darüber unterhalten keine ahnung ob ich
das irgendwie falsch de oder wie ihr das
ganze sehen oder wie er die werbung und
überhaupt findet kann ja auch sein dass
ich einfach nur durch den geschmack
dafür so richtig identifizieren kann
oder nicht richtig habe aber wenn ich
das heutige video gefallen hat fühle ich
mich auf jeden fall sehr dort über einen
daumen hoch von euch freunde merken dass
ich nicht mehr so richtig reden kann
weil
ich bin jetzt ein bisschen verwirrt
schreibt mir gern mal eure meinung zu
den werbungen hier unten in die
kommentare abonniert zudem gern meinen
kanal falls noch kein teil der lupus ist
kostenlos und verpasst keine videos mehr
und ja ich versuche jetzt ein bisschen
darauf klar zu kommen was ich mir hier
gerade angeschaut habe
[Musik]